[Music]
you watched it for free on TV then you
paid to watch the reruns on DVD you pay
to watch the reruns again on cable and
you pay to watch the reruns again again
on Netflix now get ready to pay HBO max
to watch the same reruns again again
again only this time it comes with an
all-new reunion special
again that's been indefinitely postponed
yeah it hasn't really been our day or
week or month or even our year friends
welcome to turn the century New York
where coffee shops are more than just a
place to charge your phone the sweaters
are extra chunky and the furniture
etiquette is just awful get your feet
off the couch no shoes and meet the
friends there's Joey an aspiring actor
slash human garbage disposal
and how much you give me to eat this
whole jar of olives cold cuts ice cream
limes custard good Jam good Monica a
chef with some seriously undiagnosed OCD
you see this little flower blossoms they
should be facing up not down because
well the head of the bed is where the
Sun would be you want to put the
marshmallows in concentric circles you
don't know the system her brother Ross
who goes from depressed nerd someone at
work ate my sandwich to manic unstable
buffoon in 10 short years
Rachele a sentient haircut who can only
speak in complaints
unlike officially sucks so this is
Brooklyn he made Rachel cry Rachel
always cries
Chandler an insecure manchild who uses
humor to run away from his psychological
issues I have issues with commitment
intimacy I make jokes when I'm
uncomfortable I'm hopeless and awkward
and desperate for love and Phoebe she's
a wannabe musician with a mother who
committed suicide my mom killed herself
a father who abandoned her my real dad's
the one that ran out on us before I was
born and his stepfather in prison you
know how my stepdads in prison
causing her to grow up in the streets I
was living in a box I used to beg for
money Sunday I'll tell you about the
time I stabbed the cop who's estranged
identical twins donor identity to do
porn stop using my name and shame on you
and the dead woman she thought was her
mother wasn't actually her mother and
her real mother was alive the whole time
I'm your mother
you know what this is too depressing
let's discard the weird way the only guy
I've ever been crazy about is the one
the mints can have my neighbors I may
never see him again it's a baby
if you want to know what New York was
like in the 90s read a history book or
something I don't know but if you want
to know what a sitcom set in New York in
the 90s was like friends is the show for
you
watch these sporadically unemployed
20-somethings live in
multimillion-dollar apartments and it's
a good thing that there's no crime
because these doors will never be locked
we have got to start locking that door
that would be a sensible idea watch as
they consume some of the finest legally
clearable products of the decade like
dyani water Villa wafers died napple
Quran feared venit via and Sprite oh all
set against network TVs version of New
York's true melting pot featuring a
diverse cast of characters like okay
let's see here oh here we go
waiter receptionist son you'd be right
with you
clerk how can I help you coworker you
never see again
sassy seems like I would have remembered
you and two of Ross's short-term
girlfriends come on everybody at least
they tried let's give them a round of
applause for doing the bare minimum
through it all experience the ups and
downs of one of TV's worst love stories
Ross and Rachel two of the least
compatible people in entertainment
history
watch this neurotic intellectual and the
spoiled anti intellectual clash as Ross
likes Rachel then Rachel likes Ross but
Ross has a girlfriend
so Ross dumps his girlfriend hates
Rachel but they immediately break up
then get back together then go on a
break they'd break up again then Rachel
decide she likes Ross again so he dumps
another girlfriend then they immediately
break up and Rachel wants Ross back so
he says the wrong name at the altar and
gets divorced but now Ross doesn't want
to get together then they get drunkenly
married in Vegas then divorced then Ross
gets Rachel pregnant but they don't get
back together but also they're jealous
of each other but also they still decide
not to get together Rachel decides to
move to Paris and rejects Ross but that
immediately changes her mind and they
actually do get together just in time
for the series finale
are you people cheering for I give this
thing ten minutes tops so settle in to
binge one of the most iconic sitcoms of
all time featuring all the unforgettable
moments you love churn and allure ball
Regina phalange dr. drake ramoray's
just know what you're signing up for
because when you watch this weekly show
all at once you start noticing things
like how inexplicably horny the
characters are stop staring at my
breasts it's nice and tight there it is
when's the dirty stuff started how cold
the studio is can you see my nipples
through this shirt that then layer of
game panic that covers everything
let your risk up not so much oh hey
what's my boy doing with the Barbie
how goes the dancing gay yet I see what
you mean that's quite nice wolf whose
hand beer and the realization that every
character in the show has just one
reaction to literally anything that
happens oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god stop it
starry Cougar Town origins bangs of New
York Ross Dress for Less
Fiona crapple Matt LeBlanc look on his
face the bing bang theory poultry the
Jenny the one from screen junkies
hooking up with relatives you don't kiss
your friend's mom you think would be
okay if I asked out your system I fooled
around with Joey's sister Chandler
getting handsy I ever panties right
there in my drawer mine is the red one
you took your eggs and you left this is
smack dab in the middle of the boom
capital R capital T I want to go through
the tunnel to the other side you're the
worst best man ever
you freaked out don't judge me I'm only
human good I did that report be any
later cookies margaritas be any stronger
could that shot be any prettier
could I be one anymore could I be any
more turned off could I be more sorry
bad dancing
[Music]
oh come on
I know ugly naked guy ugly naked guy got
a ThighMaster ugly naked guys LAN
kitchen tile ugly naked guys taking his
turkey out of the oven ugly naked guys
decorating his tree ugly naked guys
using his new hammer ugly naked guys
gonna make it friend ugly naked guy
looks we still 90 star since when do you
roll a bit laserdisc marathon Walker
Texas Ranger Yasmine Bleeth Sony
Playstation
Joey Buttafuoco's swing dance lessons
what about those Good Will Hunting guys
Tom Hanks meg Ryan they get mail y2k
panic Chicken Soup for the Soul
which one was deep impact and which one
was Armageddon Stephen Baldwin Mia Hamm
God milk I read about in a Maxum stupid
gap on every corner how you doing how
you doing how you doing how you doing
are you doing how you do it guest stars
[Applause]
and tweens have you got a minute are you
a friend of Rachel's I found my
identical head to it you know it's twins
right oh yeah why could I find someone
who looks exactly like me
dear white people
so the jelly star in an early
off-broadway production of interstellar
I'm gonna get on this spaceship but when
I return two hundred years from now
you'll be long gone but I want to be
aged at all need more friends click let
to find more shows that will scratch
that friends inch and click write to
hang out with your screen junkies
friends on SJ you our daily pop-culture
morning show pivot pivot pivot how you
doing